[Music]
jordan starts off this hour in portland
oregon hi jordan welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave how are you doing today better
than i deserve man what's up
good no dave i
doubt you remember me but i spoke with
you i believe in april or may of this
year
uh and i'm coming back to share some
great success uh you know i i
sold my property i had back in denver um
my wife and i were just getting ready to
get married and
now that's happened the house is sold
what it's paid for we're debt-free
we put a down payment on a beautiful
house we're getting ready to close here
at the end of december or beginning of
december great and um
yeah it's fantastic it feels like a huge
accomplishment and you know it
definitely had its ups and downs when we
got back from our honeymoon i actually
lost my job
um so a little hiccup but i'm glad that
we had that you know or our deaths taken
care of and now i'm back to work making
more than i did before and my wife's got
a job that she loves too and
um
we're i feel bad though um all things
considered things are going pretty well
um
i
went through this buying process
of this property i mean we found this
house together
but when it came to paying for the house
it all came down to
my credit and for the mortgage um you
know my wife's
didn't have good enough credit to be on
the mortgage with us but she's you know
an equal owner of this property with me
uh but now that you know we're
definitely we're getting ready to close
on this house
she kind of admitted it to me today that
she felt a little bit left out of the
process and she wants to be a little
more involved with finances and
i feel bad that you know i didn't really
take that into consideration beforehand
i'm looking for some guidance from you
all and to see you know what can i do
better
to help make sure that she's involved
with this process and
and how we can
you know how i can get her acclimated to
what the finances look like if that
makes sense
well it's interesting jordan because
what comes to mind for me this this
house buying while it's super exciting
and yes it's a big deal it is
one step
one piece of your financial journey what
i what jumps out to me that is way more
important is that your wife is involved
in the day-to-day finances in the
monthly budget and the conversations
where you guys as a team come together
and say hey what are the goals we're
working on and how are both of our
values represented and both of us have
equal ownership and equal um
you know responsibility and that that to
me is what makes the
unity piece so powerful in relation to
your marriage when it comes to finances
buying a house is a is a one-time thing
like that happens it's gonna you're
gonna close when you close and and i i
mean i can see how she would feel that
way if there was some type of
conversations in those meetings where
she felt shame or less than or something
and that's something that you know is
valid and i'm glad that you're you're
asking and i'm glad that you care um but
i i would not see that continuing to be
an issue i'm just guessing here but i
wouldn't see that continuing to be an
issue day to day in your marriage and
managing your finances dave i don't know
i don't know if i'm missing a piece of
this i think you're there
to christy's point
doing a detailed
budget before the month begins and both
of you agreeing on that
sharon and i've been married 39 years
and if we are agreeing on our calendar
and we talk calendars like we talk
budgets matter of fact maybe more detail
on calendars these days
and um and we're agreeing on our budget
and we've agreed that neither one of us
make large
financial decisions without the other
one involved
and including giving including
buying something i don't come home with
a new car and go look what i did you
know i mean we don't do that
we talk about anything we're going to
buy before we buy it that's pretty
simple
and um you know now it may be that
she's redecorating
and i'm just like okay
what are we going to spend we're going
to spend x all right i'm good with that
now then she goes and does 9 000 details
associated with that but i'm in the loop
enough that i i didn't get surprised by
the sticker shock of uh us redecorating
again
and so um
but uh uh but yeah so all right maybe
i'm buying a toy uh or something and i'm
going hey you know this is what i'm
looking at doing are you okay with this
yeah and then she doesn't have anything
else to do with it i go do it so you but
but she's in the loop on the decision
and the monthly budget the the rhythm of
where the money's going around the house
what we're doing with that
that puts it all together so
i'm kind of with christy i kind of think
you're not doing that part if you're
doing that part it'll probably solve the
big part yeah the one thing i would add
to that is you're talking dave because
you make such a good point of the other
person being in the loop on the decision
even if they're not going to
have an interest in necessarily
redecorating or the toy or whatever they
know about the purchase and one of the
things that matt and i have put in place
years ago
is we just simply
do not make any type of financial
decision until we are totally on the
same page and i know that's probably
common sense for you and i but i want to
say it out loud because some people
might just be like oh well and they go
ahead and do it and it's showing respect
to the other person to hold on any big
decisions on any decisions until you
guys get on the same page and so so be
willing to work through that those type
of conversations
that's what's going to create the unity
in your marriage
that's going to make a big difference
jordan so it could be that you kind of
she said yeah let's get a house you went
and got it
and she wasn't involved in the process
enough uh as far as that goes and she's
actually gonna live there so uh whether
she's on the credit or not you're on the
credit doesn't matter to me at all
that's not part of this conversation so
good question